- [Zac] Michael Audrey Myers
was born in the year 1957,
as the second child in his family
after his nine year old sister, Judith.
In this video, I'm only analyzing
the original timeline of Michael's life,
which includes the events
of Halloween, Halloween II,
Return, Revenge and Curse.
The date of Michael's
birth in this timeline
is not explicitly stated, but
in Halloween Resurrection,
which is part of a different
timeline, we learn this...
- Michael Myers.
Born October 19th, 1957.
- [Zac] Both of these timelines
start with the same movie,
Halloween, which would imply
that Michael was also born
on October 19th in that movie.
I like to think about
the Halloween timeline
as a train map, which I
call the Halloween Express.
So think about it like this.
If we depart from the
station, Halloween 1,
at exactly 10:19, we can go straight,
and end up in Curse of Michael Myers,
or we can go this way, and end
up at Halloween Resurrection.
No matter which way we went,
we still departed from the
Halloween 1 station at 10:19.
The counter-argument to that
idea is Halloween (2018).
In Rick Rosenthal's Halloween II,
we learn Michael Myers and
Laurie Strode are siblings,
which would mean that
they were always siblings,
even in Halloween 1.
However, in Halloween (2018),
they don't appear to be related,
because the 40-year timeline
does not pass through Halloween II.
However, it's possible that
they still are related,
just nobody ever finds out.
- Wasn't it her brother
who like cold blooded
murderated all those teenagers?
- No. That's just a myth
that some people made up
to make him feel better I think.
- There are other retcons
that don't carry over to other timelines,
so all I'll say with certainty
is that Michael was born
sometime in the year 1957.
Yeah, this is gonna be
one of *those* episodes of Horror History.
Michael was three years old
when his sister Laurie was born
in February 1961.
His early childhood is
presumably a normal one,
until two and a half years later,
when he is cursed by an
ancient demon known as Thorn.
To learn what really happened to Michael
after disappearing from Haddonfield,
stick around to the end of this video.
(upbeat music)
Welcome to Horror History,
and welcome aboard the Halloween Express.
The Halloween Timeline
can be a little bit confusing at times.
We've got many different continuities
branching out from the first two movies.
Then we've got a reboot, which
isn't connected to anything
and Halloween III, a separate world
where the original
Halloween is just a movie.
On top of that there are comics and novels
whose status in the canon
can be kind of unclear.
So to make things easy, for this episode,
we're gonna be traveling
right down the original route,
as we analyze horror's
most iconic slasher.
Michael Myers was named after
a real life Michael Myers
by the original director, John Carpenter,
who wanted to honor the
European distributor
of his previous film,
Assault on Precinct 13.
To understand how Michael
became the soulless,
immortal killer that he is,
we've gotta take it way
back to about 500 BCE.
(soft music)
The Myers family is descended
from an ancient Druid tribe
who worshiped great astronomical deities.
The Druids were a mysterious Celtic order
known for their studies
of religious scriptures,
philosophy, astronomy, and divine lore.
They were said to make sacrifices,
which sometimes included human sacrifices
for the sick or injured,
which allegedly included the burning
of huge wickerwork
figures filled with men.
Not much is known of Druid culture,
because they did not keep any records,
but around 500 BCE they did
create an ancient alphabet
carved into stone and wood ruins.
These ruins were used for Pagan rituals
in order to help the tribe
predict future events.
One of the icons was the symbol of Thorn,
which was designed after
the Thorn constellation
and was used to represent an ancient demon
that plagued the Celtic people.
- [Tommy] Among the ancient Druids,
Thorn represented a demon
that spread sickness,
destroyed crops,
brought death to hundreds
of thousands of people.
According to Celtic legend,
one child from each tribe
was chosen to be inflicted
with the Curse of Thorn.
- While knowledge of the
demon Thorn faded into legend
over the coming millenia,
the bloodline of the tribe stayed intact,
and one offshoot of the population
ended up in the Midwest
region of the United States.
They continued to practice
their ritualistic sacrifices
in fear of the malicious demon,
and they called themselves
The Cult of Thorn.
In the early 1960s,
the leader of the cult was a man
by the name of Terence Wynn,
who worked at a sanitarium
known as Smith's Grove by day
and used the facility as a meeting place
and a worship ground by night.
- One child from each tribe
was chosen to be inflicted
with The Curse of Thorn.
To offer the blood
sacrifices of its next of kin
on the night of Samhain.
- Halloween.
- The sacrifice of one family
meant sparing the lives
of an entire tribe.
- So Dr. Wynn believed
that if he and his cult
placed The Curse of Thorn
on one child,
the child would be compelled
to kill his entire family,
but the rest of the
tribe would be protected
from things like disease,
death, plague and drought
for an entire generation.
I do not know how their
selection process went,
but Dr. Wynn ends up
choosing a 6-year old boy
by the name of Michael Audrey Myers.
The curse must be placed
during the Festival of Samhain.
- [Loomis] Sam Hain.
- Which is a Gaelic
festival of Pagan origins
where the barrier would supposedly be down
between the real and the
unreal, allowing sacrifices,
be those crops, animals,
or in the case of the Halloween
movies human sacrifices,
to be made.
Samhain takes place every year
at the end of the harvest season.
Today, in the northern hemisphere,
we call that Halloween night.
However, in the eyes of the cult,
some Halloween nights were
more special than others.
- [Tommy] The Druids were also great
mathematicians and astronomers.
The thorn symbol is actually
a constellation of stars
that appears from time to
time on Halloween night.
Whenever it appears, he appears.
- I'd like to note that
the Druids, the Pagans,
The Festival of Samhain...
- [Loomis] Sam Hain.
- And the ritualistic
sacrifice of crops and animals
during the festival
are based on real life,
while the Cult of Thorn and the
Thorn constellation are not,
but the name Thorn is
based off of a letter
in the old English alphabet.
It looks kind of like a
"p" and a "b" put together
so they made the movie version
just look a little bit more thorny.
The thorn constellation
in the Halloween movies
appears in the sky at
seemingly random intervals.
They're just the same years
that the Halloween movies come out.
It's first appearance in
Michael's lifetime comes in 1963
and this is the night
that Dr. Wynn and his cult
placed the curse on the young boy,
forever changing his behavior
and making him an empty,
soulless killing machine.
In my Things You Missed
episode on Halloween (1978),
I talked about how
Michael's actions that night
could be interpreted as representing
a release of psychosexual trauma
that Michael was too young to understand.
I went in depth with the
psychological interpretation
on that video,
because it doesn't fall in line
with the information
presented in Halloween 6,
The Curse of Michael Myers.
So in this video, since we're
analyzing the entire character
that psychological interpretation
doesn't make sense.
Michael is simply possessed by the cult.
Michael Myers' power is
described by Dr. Wynn
as something greater than a
man driven to commit crimes.
- Evil.
Pure,
uncorrupted,
ancient.
- [Zac] On October 31st, 1963,
Michael's parents go out for the evening,
and his older sister is
hanging out with her boyfriend,
so he's left in the care of an older woman
named Mrs. Blankenship across the street.
He begins to hear a voice in his head.
Presumably, this was
the voice of Dr. Wynn,
or possibly the demon Thorn itself.
- Michael heard a voice?
- It told him to kill his family.
- And that's exactly what he does.
He grabs a knife and goes
to take out his sister
by stabbing her several times,
before his parents eventually come home
to discover what he had done.
Michael is sentenced to
Smith's Grove Sanitarium
and assigned to a doctor
named Samuel Loomis.
In a hearing six months
later, in April 1964,
Loomis was instructed to
report on Michael's progress
to the court two times a year.
- Further, Michael Audrey Myers
shall be brought before the court
on the day of his 21st birthday,
where he shall be tried as an adult.
- Michael was seemingly
in a catatonic state,
causing nearly everyone
to see him as harmless
other than Dr. Loomis.
His initial stay at Smith's
Grove lasted 15 years,
none of which is documented
in the Halloween films.
However, the non-canon
Chaos Comics material
tells of Michael's
involvement in more murders.
These stories occasionally
contradict the canon,
but they were written to go in tandem
with Michael's original story,
so, no they don't technically
count as part of his history,
but let's go over them briefly.
Michael was sent to room with
a number of male patients,
one of which was a psychopath
named Tony O'Malley
who got into a scuffle with
Michael one night before bed
and had to be separated
by a security guard.
He was put off by Michaels
non-speaking nature
and plans to attack him in his sleep,
but Michael was not asleep
and shoved a crayon,
or depending on where
you're from, a cray yawn,
into Tony's left eye.
Tony was actually one of the
few Michael victims to survive,
but the crayon, or cray yawn,
pressed up against his brain,
causing him to become more
delusional and violent,
landing him in a padded cell
for solitary confinement.
In November 1964, a
juvenile named Adrian Wade,
who suffered from an
obsessive eating disorder,
ate a cake that was intended for Michael,
so Michael trapped him in the showers
and tortured him with scalding hot water.
He was found unconscious
with multiple burns,
and later died in the hospital
wing of heart failure.
Years would go by without incident,
and most of the staff considered
Michael a model patient,
but then in 1971, another young patient,
a self-harmer named Roger,
who claimed to have witnessed
Michael's attack on Tony O'Malley,
was found after supposedly
biting off his own tongue
and choking on it.
If you're familiar with Michael,
you can probably assume
that that's not how
things really went down.
That Halloween, one of the
asylum's administrators
decided to put on a
Halloween party for the kids,
and Michael wore a clown costume,
the same costume he wore when
he jabbed Judith in 1963.
A girl named Nancy teased
Michael for having cooties.
During a game of bobbing for apples,
lightning struck the building,
causing the power to go out,
and in the cover of darkness,
Michael drowned her,
and disappeared before
the lights came back up.
When Loomis discovers what
happened, he is furious,
frustrated by his patient's
continued silence,
and nearly strikes the boy
before being stopped by
his fiance, Jennifer.
Jennifer mentions that she believes
Michael belongs in a prison,
which Michael seems to hear,
and he decides to make
her his next target.
He throws her off the
roof of the building,
and it is ruled that she
made the jump herself.
What do all of these Chaos
Comics victims have in common?
They all did something
Michael didn't like,
whether it's aggression,
stolen food, accusations,
general teasing or wishing ill on him,
all of these characters
suffer from a form of revenge.
In the Cult of Thorn arc,
that's not how Michael operates,
he is driven by a supernatural evil
that tells him what to
do and he has one goal,
which we'll talk about later.
That's part of why the comics
are not considered canon,
so let's get back to what is canon,
the original rampage
that would take place on
Halloween night October 1978.
(soft music)
Michael Myers turns 21 years old,
and so, was due back in court
to be tried as an adult.
Dr. Loomis and Nurse Marion Chambers
were supposed to transport
him to his trial,
so Michael took action to make sure
that this was not possible.
He destroyed his room at Smith's Grove,
freed many of his fellow captives,
and left behind word "sister" in blood,
although to most, this
appeared to be a reference
to his older sister, Judith,
because his younger sister's existence
was hidden from the public,
and she was given a
new name and new family
so that she would be protected
from any potential harassment.
Since Dr. Wynn was the
administrator of the sanitarium,
and also the leader of the Cult of Thorn,
it's not hard to imagine
that he didn't exactly try his hardest
to prevent Michael's escape.
Michael waits for Loomis and Chambers
to pull up to the sanitarium,
and when Loomis gets out
to use the nearby phone,
he attacks Marion, driving
her out of the vehicle
which he takes for himself.
I know you can play as Michael
Myers in Dead by Daylight,
but I think this is proof
that he should also be playable in GTA.
(phone rings)
- [Roman] Let's go bowling.
- [Zac] Michael's ability to drive
without any training or experience
has always been a point of question,
one that's even brought up in the movie.
- [Wynn] Sam, Haddonfield
is 150 miles away from here,
now for God's sake, he can't drive a car!
- He was doing very well last night.
- When you consider the fact
that Michael is no
ordinary mental patient,
but rather more of a vessel
for this ancient evil known as Thorn,
this starts to make more sense.
Throughout his story, we
discover many of the powers
granted to him by Thorn,
so the ability to operate a
car doesn't seem far fetched.
During his 1978 rampage,
Michael is trying to recreate
the experience he had when
killing his older sister in 1963.
I like to think of it as a ritual
that he established when he was six,
going after his older sister,
and now he's trying to recreate it
going after his younger sister.
When he was six, he wore a
one-piece clown suit and mask,
his Halloween costume,
so this time he puts
together a similar attire.
He runs a mechanic's truck off
the road and annihilates him
to get the one piece suit, and
when he gets into Haddonfield
he breaks into the general store
and steals his now iconic mask,
in place of the clown mask.
He also steals some rope,
which he would use later.
Next, he breaks into his old
home, which now sits abandoned.
When they later investigate the
house, they find a dead dog,
which Loomis has his own explanation for.
- He got hungry.
- Okay, he knows his patient best,
so I'm willing to accept that explanation.
At this point his sister,
Laurie, stops by the house
to leave a key under the mat
at the request of her adoptive father,
who is a realtor who's
trying to sell the place.
Michael sees her walk up to the front door
and leave the key, but
he lets her walk away,
and stares at her as she makes
her way towards her school.
Did Michael immediately know
that this was his sister,
or did Laurie become a target
simply because he was angry
that his old house was being sold?
We'll get our answer a little bit later,
but for now, we just need to know
that Michael was planning to make Laurie
one of his future victims.
I also wondered why he stalks
Laurie throughout the day
instead of just killing her right now.
He follows her to school
and stares her down through the window
during her English class,
then after killing some time skulking
around the elementary school,
keeps surveillance on
Laurie and her friends
as they walk home from school.
When Annie yells out at him, he even stops
and seems to consider killing
them all right then and there,
but doesn't.
So what's the big hold up?
Obviously the real reason
is that the movie would
only be 22 minutes long
if he killed them in daylight,
but also in 1963, Michael given his curse
as part of the Festival of Samhain.
- [Loomis] Sam Hain.
- And if we go back to
the holiday's origins
in Celtic Ireland,
it was celebrated starting in
the evening on October 31st.
- [Annie] Subtle, isn't he?
- So if Michael is waiting for nightfall
for the sake of tradition,
that may also explain what he does next.
He stops by the cemetery and
steals his sister's tombstone,
with plans to use it as a prop
during his recreation of her death.
Instead of an immediate
sibling slice and dice,
he just keeps an eye on Laurie,
staring from behind some hedges,
watching her through her bedroom window,
and following her and Annie
as they head to their
babysitting jobs that evening.
When they arrive, he
waits for them to park
and watches them go to
their respective jobs.
Remember, if you've seen my
Things You Missed episode
on the original Halloween,
you saw me provide a
different interpretation
for Michael's behavior that afternoon,
because I was analyzing the
movie as a stand alone story.
But in this Horror History episode,
I'm analyzing Michael's entire character,
and the context provided by
the sequels in this timeline
changes how I have to look at him.
It's all about the family connection
because Michael has to
sacrifice his entire family
before being freed by Thorn.
Of course, having a massive amount
of retroactive continuity like this
can kind of mess up the
story if you aren't careful,
and let's face it, this isn't Saw,
the continuity wasn't the biggest concern.
So the next thing that Michael does
is go after the sex-crazed teens
babysitting across the
street from the Doyle house
where Laurie is babysitting.
If I'm gonna try to slap on a
reasoning for his actions here
the curse of Thorn is what's
telling Michael what to do,
and Thorn likes human sacrifice,
so any extra victims that
Michael can decease along the way
are bonus points,
even if they aren't a
part of Michael's family.
It's like how I might go
out to get a steak taco,
but once I see the menu I'm
probably gonna add the nachos,
cinnamon twists, horchata,
and probably like three
additional steak tacos
if we're being real.
The way Michael goes after his victims
can only be described
with one word, unsettling.
Everything he does is very methodical,
from his slow walking, to
his empty staring into space,
to his complete silence as he does it all.
This creates the impression
that he's essentially a blank
slate, void of character,
almost like a machine
programmed by the curse
that has been placed on him.
This not only fits the
idea of the character,
essentially being a shape
that does these things
without interjecting any personality,
but also taps into elements
that the human mind
perceives as unsettling.
The core reason that people
can be easily off-put
by the idea of voyeurism
goes back to basic survival instinct.
When humans lived in the wild,
if another lurking
animal had eyes on them,
it was most likely a predator
getting ready to strike.
So we're genetically predisposed
to be uncomfortable in these
situations and avoid them.
One of the first studies on
the sensation of being watched
was called "The Feeling
of Being Stared At,"
a title almost as fitting to it's content
as the title of that
80s movie with the blob
which was called, "The Blob."
The article's author, Dr. Edward Titchener
disproves the idea that
someone's gaze itself
could be what gives you those goosebumps.
That unsettled feeling you get
is something you give yourself.
In fact, an actual voyeur
isn't even necessary,
you can get creeped out just by believing
that you are being watched.
Michael takes advantage
of this by popping in,
being seen by the victim
that he's stalking,
and then disappearing,
leaving his target to wonder
if he's still somewhere nearby,
zeroing in on them with
that piercing stare.
- Laurie, the Boogeyman's outside, look.
- Tommy, there's nobody outside.
- But it would not be long
before Michael Myers's apparent voyeurism
would escalate into much
more dangerous behavior.
Michael's night continues
as he focuses on Laurie's friend Annie,
who is babysitting at the
Wallace house across the street.
He starts by locking
her in the laundry room,
then after she gets out,
he eavesdrops as she makes
evening plans with her boyfriend.
And by evening plans, I mean se...
Michael hides inside of her car
as she drops off the little girl, Lindsey,
across the street at the Doyle's house,
and when she comes back
she hops into the vehicle
to go pick up Paul,
and he lets her discover
that she's not alone
before getting down to business.
And by business, I mean killing her.
(dramatic music)
He didn't even have the
courtesy to phone Paul
and let him know that
his ride is cancelled.
He moves Annie's body
inside for later use.
When he comes back downstairs,
he discovers two more
horny teens have appeared,
Linda and her boyfriend Bob,
who were getting at it on the couch.
After they move things upstairs,
Bob heads down to the kitchen for a drink,
and Michael surprises him by doing this.
(dramatic music)
He pins Bob to the wall
with a butcher's knife,
then further conceals his identity
by dressing up as a bedsheet ghost
which, I mean, if he
wanted to pretend to be Bob
in order to trick Linda,
he's already in a costume,
he's rocking the mask and jumpsuit.
But I guess the bedsheet
ghost maybe does a better job
of concealing his physique,
because he's much more
physically imposing than Bob.
Putting Bob's glasses
over the ghost costume
is enough to convince Linda
that that's her boyfriend,
and when she turns her
back to him to call Laurie,
he strangles her with the phone cord.
With all three of Laurie's
friends across the street
out of commission,
Michael turns out the last
remaining lights in the house,
much like how the sanitarium went dark
before he took out his
fellow patient Nancy in 1971.
He then arranges the body of Annie
in the upstairs bedroom under
the Judith Myers's tombstone
as a tribute to his first ever attack,
and waits for his younger
sister to stumble upon it.
Linda is stuffed in a closet
and Bob is hung up in the closet
with the rope he stole earlier.
Good planning.
After discovering this, Laurie
stumbles out of the room
in a mess of emotions,
and Michael emerges from the
darkness of the room next door,
in what is probably the
coolest shot in Halloween.
She is chased back across the street,
and tries to defend herself
by sticking a knitting
needle through his neck,
which does cause him to drop
to the floor for some time.
If you're watching this video,
you probably already know that
Michael Myers is invincible,
and this is a result of
the powers he acquires
by being cursed by the
ancient demon, Thorn.
But at the same time, he isn't
just an unstoppable machine.
Hurting him enough will put him down
for short periods of time,
which I refer to as his "recharge period."
When he comes back to, he
follows Laurie up the stairs
and finds her tending to the kids,
but now his focus is on his sister.
He finds her hiding in a bedroom
closet and busts through.
Lights on? No! Lights off.
Laurie resourcefully pokes his
eye out with a coat hanger,
which puts him down long enough
for her to get out of the room
and get the kids out of the house.
Michael gets a quick ab workout in,
and then comes for her once more
and she's only just able
to rip off his mask,
which completely shocks him for a moment.
This is one of the few times
we see his face as an adult,
and he looks shocked, almost like the mask
is such an important part of this ritual
that he can't believe she's removed it.
As he puts it back on, he's
shot by someone in the dark
and stumbles back into the bedroom.
It turns out to be his old
psychiatrist Dr. Loomis,
who unloads five more bullets into him,
knocking him off the patio and
onto the Doyle's front lawn.
But as always, Michael's
ailment is only temporary,
and he flees the scene to recoup.
He hides out in a back alley
as the police close in on the Doyle house.
Now left without a weapon,
he goes up to a random
residence to restock,
and arms himself with a carving knife
stolen from Mrs. Elrod's cutting board.
Then, just to make sure the knife works,
I guess, he breaks into the
house of their neighbor, Alice
and successfully tests it out on her.
I could try to dissect
why the Elrods got to live
and Alice didn't but I
think it's better not to.
Part of what makes this
iteration of Michael scary
for audiences is his unpredictability,
you don't really know
when he's going to strike.
This must be when Michael broke
into his old Elementary
School and left this clue
that would later be found by police.
It's a child-like drawing
of a family on Halloween,
potentially Michael's family,
with a knife stuck into the sister.
On the left, there seems to
already be a discarded body,
which probably represents Judith,
meaning that this girl
with the knife in her
most likely represents Laurie,
and this answers one of
our questions from earlier
on in this video.
Initially, it was unclear if Michael knew
that Laurie was his other
sister when he first spotted her
at the Myers house,
and I speculated that
maybe he went after her
because he was simply
upset that she was involved
in his childhood home being
put on the real estate market.
So this drawing, if I'm
interpreting it correctly,
which will surely be up for debate,
would prove that he did know about Laurie
and he was targeting her specifically.
He also paints the word Samhain...
- [Loomis] Sam Hain.
- [Zac] Onto the chalkboard
as a tribute to his demonic lord Thorn,
since the Curse of Thorn
that has afflicted him
all these years is part
of a ritual carried out
during the Festival of Samhain.
- [Loomis] Sam Hain.
- It seems like the
lesson on the chalkboard
may have already been
there when Michael arrived,
but it's also possible
that it's no coincidence,
seeing as how it's an astronomy lesson,
and the date of each of
Michael's homicidal rampages
is determined by the alignment of planets
in the solar system.
At this point, news of
a killer in Haddonfield
is spreading all over the media,
which at the time meant TV and radios,
and Michael overhears where
Laurie is being taken,
from this cowboy's boombox.
Yee-haw, roll it.
- [On Radio] There is one survivor,
17-year old Laurie Strode
was found directly across
the street from the home
where the murders took place.
The teenager was taken across town
to Haddonfield Memorial Clinic.
(eerie music)
- It must have been getting close
to Michael's bedtime or something,
because after hearing this,
he just lets the next 17
teenagers he crosses paths with
go free.
Seriously, I counted, he just
goes straight to the hospital
and dumps out the rest
of his cherry slurpee
in the dumpster.
He promptly heads downstairs
to hide in the nursery,
before continuing on to the store room
where he's able to slash
through the phone lines,
effectively isolating Laurie
and the hospital staff
from calling in outside help.
One by one, he takes out
each of the staff members
at the hospital taking care of Laurie,
starting with the security
guard Mr. Garrett,
who gets tomahawked with
the pointy end of a hammer,
and then an EMT named Bud
gets choked from behind
after making love to his girlfriend Karen
in a hydrotherapy bath.
After doing so, he cranks
up the heat of the bath
to over 130°F in preparation
of his next kill.
Remember how Michael used a ghost costume,
pretending to be Bob in
order to get close to Linda
earlier that evening?
Now, Michael pretends to be Bud
while Karen's back is turned,
and when he gets close enough,
he dunks her repeatedly in the bath.
In my opinion this takes the
cake in terms of brutality.
- Brutality!
- They say that burning and drowning
are the two most painful ways to die,
and this is a combination of both.
In fact, if you look at TheTopTens,
which is a website that lets the internet
vote on ranking things,
people have agreed that
burning to death and drowning
would be the worst two ways to go.
Of course, we'll never know for sure,
seeing as how everyone who
participated in this poll
was still alive but you get the idea.
On top of that, I can only
imagine the stark terror
that Karen felt,
because she thought she was
in the safe protective hands
of her boyfriend, and she
turns around to realize
that it's actually this
terrifying masked man.
She's also undressed,
so add a feeling of
vulnerability to the equation,
and this is just not an ideal way
to spend your final moments.
It seems like Michael just
wants to clear out anyone
who could pose as an obstacle
to him getting to Laurie,
and the next person in his way
was most likely Nurse Virginia Alves.
Michael catches her in
one of the surgery rooms
and ties her down to an operating table,
then hooks her up to
a severed IV catheter,
so she's unable to move
as her blood slowly
drains out of her body.
He continues to the office
of Dr. Frederick Mixter
and prescribes him with
20 CCs of medication,
injected directly into his right eye,
then when Nurse Janet Marshall
comes to check on him,
Michael appears out of the dark
and jabs the blood vessel in her temple
with an air-filled syringe,
which essentially creates an
air bubble in your bloodstream
and stops the flow of blood to the brain,
which is usually lethal.
It seems his very straightforward
and methodical way of going about things,
doesn't hold him back
from getting creative
with some of his kills.
With all of the staff that
regularly walk the corridors
of the main lobby either
dead or trying to find help,
Michael has free reign
to slow-walk his way
right into Laurie's room uncontested.
Now armed with a surgical scalpel,
he sees his target apparently unconscious
due to the medication she's
on, and decides to get stabby.
(eerie music)
When he realizes she's not there,
he looks to the security
monitors to find her,
and heads in her direction,
but first he comes across a conversation
between the last two
remaining hospital employees,
a nurse named Jill Franco
and an ambulance attendant named Jimmy.
He overhears Jimmy instruct her
to drive to the Sheriff's Station for help
if she doesn't find
anyone in the east wing,
so while she's searching the
other side of the building,
Michael goes out to the parking lot
and disables all of the vehicles,
by stabbing the tires and
cutting their fuel lines.
As Jill comes back in,
Michael hears her
calling out Laurie's name
and goes towards the sound.
Just before she realizes he's there,
he drives the scalpel
into her back so hard
that he's able to lift
her up off the ground,
with the small blade holding
up her entire weight.
This is where another one of the abilities
that The Curse has granted
him starts to become clear,
in addition to being immortal,
he's also acquired superhuman strength.
With one more staff member out of the way
and his main target finally
in his line of sight again,
he goes after her,
but his refusal to walk
anywhere near a normal pace
doesn't do him any favors,
and Laurie gets away in an elevator.
However it's not long before
Michael catches her outside,
how 'bout that?
He's almost able to reach her,
before someone lets her
back into the building.
Michael just crashes through the door
like a deer in a hair salon.
(screams)
And sees Dr. Loomis and Nurse Chambers
trying to protect Laurie.
His old psychiatrist is armed and ready,
and shoots him five more times,
bringing the grand total
to 11 on the night.
As we've seen to be the case
whenever Michael is attacked,
he collapses temporarily, but cannot die.
The state marshal that
came with Dr. Loomis
goes in for a closer look,
stupidly assuming that
Michael had stopped breathing,
and Michael springs to
life and slits his throat.
Loomis and Laurie retreat
to another operating room,
so Michael busts down that door too,
bringing him within striking
distance of his doctor.
Loomis's gun jams,
and Michael takes the opportunity
to stab him in the gut.
When he corners Laurie, she
fires a couple shots at him,
which apparently land just
above his eyes I guess?
Judging by the fact
that the mask doesn't
have any bullet holes?
The drip down from his wounds
temporarily blinds him,
and rather than just using his
hearing to try to locate her,
he just kind of flails around the room
in the general direction
where he thinks she
might be for some reason.
Laurie is audibly whimpering too,
so it should have been kind of easy.
Not one of Michael's finer moments.
Somehow though, he is able
to hear the hissing sound
of gas tanks being opened by Loomis
near the front of the room,
but before long the sound surrounds him.
The last thing he hears is
the voice of his psychiatrist.
- It is time, Michael.
- What the fu-- (BOOM)
- This is easily the biggest blast
that Mr. Myers has yet to endure.
With the mechanics of his invincibility
and recharge period
still mostly a mystery,
I can only assume that it
was his sheer willpower
and determination that kept him going,
because he knew he was so close
to finishing his sister off.
He was able to force himself
to go a little bit longer
before collapsing again,
as he had when suffering
would-be fatal blows in the past.
So to Laurie's absolute horror,
Michael actually walks out of the blaze,
literally covered in burning
flames before finally,
his body can take him no further
and he falls face forward,
where he would continue to burn
until the fire department
arrived, and found him in a coma,
this time a much more permanent one,
as he would spend the next 10
years in this comatose state.
This time, instead of being
taken back to Smith's Grove,
Michael was locked up in
a higher security facility
known as Ridgemont Federal Sanitarium,
where despite being a
vegetable for his entire stay,
he gained a reputation for
being the devil himself,
and even the guards are afraid of him.
As for the room he was locked in...
- Welcome to hell.
- After 10 years of being in a coma,
it doesn't look like Michael
is ever going to come out of it
and it was decided that
he should be moved back
to Smith's Grove to
open up space for other
and more threatening patients.
Dr. Loomis is still Michael's
doctor during this time,
though it's said that the
position is more ceremonial.
Many of the day to day decisions
fall on the Ridgemont medical
administrator, Dr. Hoffman.
Michael was to be transferred
on October 30th, 1988,
one day shy of the 10 year
anniversary of his rampage.
Extra precautions are taken
to ensure a smooth operation,
however, disaster strikes
when the ride to Smith's Grove
doesn't quite go as planned.
(soft music)
During Michael Myers' original stay
at Smith's Grove Sanitarium,
he was assumed to be relatively harmless
as more and more time passed.
He was relatively catatonic,
and only Dr. Loomis was
able to see through him
and understand that the
patient was still dangerous.
It seems that Michael employed
a similar tactic at Ridgemont
because while it's assumed
he's still comatose
during his patient transfer,
he is secretly awake and conscious
to hear the transfer personnel
discuss his living relatives.
- Did Hoffman, say anything
about living relatives?
- Yeah, a niece living in his hometown.
- Clearly, Michael is sentient
during this ambulance ride.
It would be hard to say for sure
how long he's been awake before this,
but given how he tricked
most of the sanitarium staff
as a kid, I wouldn't be surprised
if he was faking his coma
for the last couple years now.
The information about who
his living relative is
is also important because
of the Curse of Thorn.
Even if Laurie wasn't around anymore,
he still has to take out
the rest of his family
in order to spare the community at large.
Once he hears what he needs
to hear, Myers breaks free
and demonstrates his unbelievable strength
by shoving his thumb
through the man's forehead
into his skull.
They make it just south of Mill Creek,
about 4 hours outside of Haddonfield,
before the ambulance crashes,
probably the result of
Michael attacking the driver.
It ends up flipped over in a river,
talk about rolling the ambo,
but that wasn't even
the end of the suffering
for at least one of the passengers.
We can actually see carnage
smeared all over the
outside of the vehicle,
which would suggest that one
of the transfer personnel
actually survived
and may have tried to
escape the crash site
only to be reeled back in
and gutted by Michael Myers.
Since his signature mask and jumpsuit
burned up in the fire in 1978,
Michael feels the need
to get back in costume
and stops at a local auto
shop called Penny's garage.
Here, he finds a stake and
uses it to impale the mechanic
and take his jumpsuit.
He ends up hanging the guy up in chains
on the back of his tow truck.
It seems that Michael likes to make
a spectacle of his victims,
whether that be the shrine
of babysitters in 1978,
the unique cause of death for
each of the hospital staff,
the capsized ambulance, or
now, the strung up mechanic.
This, like many of his
actions, may go back to Thorn.
Perhaps Michael wants to show off his work
to gain favor with the ancient being.
Or maybe he just does this
to intimidate the survivors
as much as possible because he enjoys it.
He goes to the small diner
attached to the garage
and relieves the waitress of her duties,
by the looks of it, this
one died by strangulation.
If you don't like the service,
you don't have to leave a tip, but damn.
He also destroys all of the telephones,
a tactic that worked
well to buy him some time
before authorities showed
up at the hospital in 1978,
so why not try it again here?
It would seem that he is
looking for his next victim
inside the kitchen,
when he's confronted by
his old friend, Dr. Loomis.
His doctor tries to slow him down
with another round of lead,
but this time he gets out of the way
and tries to strand Loomis at the garage
by stealing a tow truck,
and using it to sideswipe the gas pump
to blow up Loomis' car.
Now that he's got a suit and a vehicle,
the next item on his
list is getting a mask,
and he's able to find one at
Vincent Drug in Haddonfield.
Actually, the one he gets
looks like a cheap knock-off
of the one he had, which makes sense
because his actions 10 years
ago made the mask more popular,
so they had to be
mass-produced at lower quality.
He also has a chance encounter
with his niece, Jamie Lloyd,
the living relative that
he heard about earlier,
but like he did with Laurie in the past,
he waits until nightfall
to come after her.
He stalks the house that evening,
and after Jamie and her
adoptive sister Rachel
head out for trick-or-treating,
he does a little investigating
and confirms Jamie's
relationship to Laurie Strode.
He also gets his stabbing hand warmed up
on Rachel and Jamie's dog
because he's an ***hole.
We know in previous situations
that Michael has thrived in the darkness,
like the blackout at the sanitarium,
and his turning the lights
off in the Wallace house.
This time, he goes straight to the source,
the power station in Haddonfield,
and throws the technician
into a transformer,
not only electrocuting him,
but also causing a blackout in town.
He then completely
massacres the police station
and leaves the place in ruins
and without a police force,
save for a couple of stragglers.
On a foggy backroad, he finds Rachel,
who is supposed to be
babysitting Jamie that night
and scares her away.
At least I assume that's him,
it's hard to say for sure
with all these imitators
running around.
Rachel is soon after
picked up by the police
with Jamie in tow,
and again, I assume Michael
is the one who sticks around
to see where they head.
However, the car disappears
out of his sight,
so he breaks into a different police car,
which is stationed at Jamie's house
and hides in the back seat
in order to catch a free ride
to wherever they are going.
Although the house is
supposedly locked down,
Michael still finds a way in somehow,
and eyes his next target, Deputy Logan,
who is in charge of
guarding the front door.
Once Loomis and Sheriff
Meeker leave the house,
he makes his move, literally
tearing his head and hand
from his body.
Michael takes a page from
his murder of Bob Simms
and Linda van der Klok the decade before
by pretending to someone else.
He sits in Logan's rocking chair
until the sheriff's daughter,
Kelly Meeker comes along,
and in another similarity
to the Bob Simms kill,
he impales her body up against a door,
this time using Deputy
Logan's rifle to do so.
That leaves two more human
obstacles in the house
for Michael to get through
before reaching Jamie.
Rachel and her love interest Brady.
Michael finds them on the stairs
and Brady tries to fight him physically,
but is easily no match.
Michael lifts him up and
crushes his neck and skull
with his bare hands.
He conveniently finds another
carving knife in the loft,
and comes after Rachel and Jamie with it
onto the roof of the house,
where he narrowly misses
turning the elder of the two
into a rooftop Halloween decoration.
He eventually knocks
her down onto the lawn
where she falls unconscious,
but Jamie is able to escape.
However, Michael hears the
security alarm going off
in the elementary school,
and decides to search there for her.
Suddenly having blond
hair for some reason,
he ambushes Dr. Loomis and
throws him out of the way,
and he goes flying through the door
like a doberman through a coffee table.
Michael, after quickly
popping into the bathroom
to dye his hair back to normal,
appears on the stairs behind Jamie,
and he's actually able to grab her
after she falls down the steps
and is unable to get back on her feet.
However, Rachel saves her
when she shows up to blind Michael
with a fire extinguisher
sprayed in his face.
If Malcolm in the Middle
is to be believed,
this could actually work.
However, as per usual with Michael Myers,
his blindness is only temporary,
and he's actually able
to sneak past everybody
and latch himself onto
the bottom of the truck
that comes to rescue Rachel and Jamie.
He clings to it as it
b-lines out of Haddonfield.
Anyone who's ever had to do
the arm hang in gym class
knows how much strength this requires.
I think I could handle it though.
He climbs up while the car is in motion
and defeats all three of the Illinois boys
riding in the back before
punching through the window
to tear off the face of the driver.
Rachel takes the wheel
and tries to buck him off
with some sharp turns, but
when that doesn't work,
she resorts to slamming the brakes.
Vocabulary time, I'm gonna
call that a brake yeet.
(tires screeching)
Michael gets up looking
ready to line up and block
for the Chicago Bears offense,
so Rachel just channels
her inner linebacker
and tries to run him over,
and since this would be a fatal
blow for any normal human,
it knocks him unconscious
for a period of time.
A confused Jamie wanders
into the roadside ditch
that Michael is lying
in and grabs his hand.
It's my understanding that this action
causes a mental connection
between the two,
that he was transferring
part of his curse onto her.
(eerie music)
After being rammed into a roadside ditch
with the full force of a pickup truck,
the life comes back into Michael
just a moment too late to attack Jamie,
and instead, the police and
the remaining Illinois boys
all open fire on him.
With seven men all firing shots,
Michael is knocked back into a hole.
Michael Myers is not usually
one to back away from a fight,
but I think this time he
realizes he's overmatched,
and not wanting to end back up
in a high security mental hospital,
he crawls away and finds an
opening to wiggle through
just before the police
drop a stick of dynamite into the hole
to try to finish him off.
He ends up floating down a
stream to quickly get away
and ends up at a homeless camp,
and when it's scruffy inhabitant
comes out to investigate the
disturbance, this happens.
I'm guessing Michael
just runs out of energy.
I think it's been well
established at this point
that whenever Michael survives death,
he needs some time to
regenerate his power,
to recharge himself.
We saw him take a quick rest
after being struck by the pickup truck,
but he never recharges after
being shot up by the gunmen,
because he needs to use a
little more of his energy
to get out of there before
the dynamite goes off
and puts him in another coma.
It's just back at the
hospital 10 years ago.
After the explosion, he's able
to go on a little bit longer
if he really puts in some extra effort.
So Michael was essentially
just delaying the inevitable,
and he runs out of power
once he gets some
distance from the police.
It's not clear what happens
directly after that,
but Michael would
continue to hide out there
for an entire year,
once again using the days
surrounding Halloween
as the time frame for his violent ritual.
It was October 30th, 1989,
when he finally took the knife
to his off-the-grid co-habitant,
not the nicest way to treat a guy
who gave you a free
place to live for a year,
but I guess at this point
you've probably realized
that Michael is not the nicest guy.
The next day he hides outside
of the Carruthers's home,
then breaks in the back
and spies on Rachel
as she gets herself ready to go out.
After ****ing around in
the house for a while,
he decides he's waited long enough,
and gets her with a pair of
scissors through the chest.
Rachel, like many of the victims
that Michael took out this Halloween,
is deposited into a
shrine that he's building
in the attic of the Myers House,
I already talked about how
Michael loves his shrines.
Later, Rachel's friends, Tina and Sammy,
come over to look for her,
so Michael decides to stalk
them for a little while.
Michael's just trying to
relive the good old days.
Back then it was teenage babysitters,
now it's teenage housesitters;
he'll take what he can get.
The next victim of that year's Halloween
is Tina's boyfriend, Mikey.
Mike-ULL gets a rise out of him
by leaving a scratch on his fancy car.
When Mik-EY tries to
start a fight over it,
he stops him in his tracks
by grabbing his throat,
and whacks him with what
looks to be a gardening fork.
Keeping up with the tradition
of pretending to be someone
else, he steals Mikey's car
and wears the mask that Tina got him.
She gets into the car
thinking that she's being
picked up by her boyfriend
to go to the Halloween party.
- I just love Barbaric men.
- You'll love this guy, Tina.
I also love how when
Tina tries to kiss him,
he just takes it, and then looks at her.
It's even weirder when
you think about the fact
that that's his first kiss.
She asks if they can stop
for a pack of cigarettes,
so he stops at a gas station,
and while she's inside,
he switches back
into his usual William
Shatner/Greg Nicotero looking mask,
a sign that he was
probably about to give her
the old Michael Myers special.
I am really running out of
advertiser-friendly ways
to say that Michael Myers
killed someone, okay?
However, before she gets back in the car,
the police raid the gas
station and pick her up.
They had been tipped off
that she was in danger
thanks in part to Jamie's psychic vision,
and Michael, the real
Michael Myers, that is,
flees the area.
We see this iteration of Michael Myers
start to shy away from crowds
of armed police officers,
because he knows what can happen
if he gets shot too many times,
he'll have to do his recharge thing,
and that gives authorities an opportunity
to potentially pick him up,
and he wants to avoid
going back to Smith's Grove
or any other facility at all costs.
Later that night, he shows
up at The Tower Farm,
which is home to the
biggest teen Halloween party
in Haddonfield.
He sees Tina, Sammy, and
Sammy's boyfriend, Spitz,
leave the party and go
into the barn next door.
Michael equips himself with a pitchfork,
and pitches Spitz out of the
way before grabbing a scythe
and harvesting Sammy's neck.
When he comes out of the barn,
his local infamy actually
works to his advantage,
because the cops assume
that he's just a kid that they saw earlier
who was dressed up as Michael Myers.
I can understand why a lot of
kids dressed up as him in 1988
during Halloween 4,
because it had been 10 years
since the babysitter massacre
at that point, but dressing
up as Michael in 1989,
in Haddonfield, when 17
people lost their lives to him
the prior Fall,
and he's still a wanted
criminal on the loose
and most certainly somewhere in town
because it's Halloween?
Maybe that's just not the smartest move.
But anyway, with their guard down,
he's easily able to take out
the cops with the pitchfork.
He gets back in the car, maybe
planning to go find Jamie,
when Jamie just shows up on the scene
with her little friend Billy.
This boogeyman business
is getting way too easy,
the victims are supposed
to run away from him,
not the other way around.
He starts by chasing down Tina
by intentionally driving slowly after her.
Jimmy and I talked about this
in the Halloween 5 Things You Missed.
Everyone knows that
Michael Myers walks slow.
We're never given a
concrete reason for this,
but I've always assumed
that it ties into his curse.
I talked about how he
spent his first 15 years
in Smith's Grove in near-catatonia.
He became known for being
this creepy, unmoving shape.
So he kept that aspect
of his persona in tact
by chasing his victims at
a slow and steady rate,
relying more on power than speed.
It doesn't often end up
being a detriment to him,
because his victims are usually
distracted, fear-stricken,
or stupidly brave,
so it's not often that somebody gets away.
But seeing Michael go after
someone slowly in a car
doesn't make a whole lot of sense,
since we've seen in previous scenes
that he is capable of driving fast.
The only explanation that makes sense here
is that Michael is savoring his kill,
he's intentionally stretching it out
because he enjoys being the predator,
and maybe enjoys seeing the
fear on his victims' faces
and in their body language.
(Tina screams)
- [Zac] Maybe this is also why Michael
intentionally misses Laurie with a knife
so many times on that
night in '78, who knows?
Before reaching Tina, he changes course
and comes after Jamie and Billy.
Reasoning for this?
I think maybe he didn't
see them right away?
It's pretty hard to do a
character analysis video
on someone who has so little character,
but that's also what makes him great.
Jamie zig-zags her way into the woods,
which results in Michael
crashing the car into a tree,
and somehow it explodes.
Tina's boyfriend would be
pissed if he were still alive.
Michael continues to pursue Jamie on foot,
and due to her injured leg,
it looks like he might get her
until Tina sacrifices herself
to give Jamie more time.
Michael uses the knife for this one,
a true classic never goes out of style.
Wait, wrong franchise.
That's when the rest of
the police force shows up
to rescue Jamie and Billy,
and after they're safely escorted away,
Loomis meets Michael at
the edge of the forest
with a message.
He tells Michael that
the rage that drives him
will not go away if he kills everyone,
the only way he can get rid of it
is to face it where it first began,
his childhood home on Lampkin Lane.
This is the first time we've
ever seen an internal struggle
inside of Michael.
For the last 26 years of his life,
he's been consumed by this Curse of Thorn.
All of his actions have
been motivated by it.
For the first time since then,
we would see the real Michael
Myers creeping to the surface.
(eerie music)
Before heading home to the Myers House,
Michael first makes an appearance
at the Haddonfield Children's Clinic.
This is where Jamie and Billy live.
This accomplishes a few things.
One, Michael is able to
determine that Jamie isn't there,
as promised by Loomis who is
with her at the Myers House.
Two, it draws the police
in that direction,
making it easier for Michael
to get back into his old home.
And three, he attacks one of the officers
guarding the clinic and
steals his squad car,
which he uses to drive
himself to Lamkin Lane
and rear end the only cop
still defending the perimeter,
shortly before smashing his
face in on the dashboard.
He makes his way inside, and
Loomis meets him downstairs
and tries to convince him
to put down the knife,
telling him that Jamie is the key
to putting an end to
the rage inside of him.
Michael actually hesitates
and lowers the knife at first,
and for a moment, it looks
as if his psychiatrist
is finally getting through to him.
This shows that the human
side of Michael Myers
is still down there somewhere,
and although we don't see it often,
he does want to escape the malediction
that's been inflicted upon him.
It seems that the rage wins
over in the end though,
because he comes to his senses
and slashes Dr. Loomis across the torso,
then tosses him down the stairs.
Michael goes after Jamie,
but she scurries away,
so he gets his fix by tying
a rope around this cop's neck
and tossing him out the window.
Michael chases Jamie downstairs,
then down to the basement,
then upstairs, then up to the attic.
Jamie discovers what happened
to Rachel and her dog Max,
and in a last ditch effort,
lies down inside the coffin
that Michael has setup for her
and attempts to have a heart
to heart with her Uncle.
Surprisingly, Jamie is
actually able to get through
to the human side of Michael Myers
in a way that Dr. Loomis
was never able to.
She asks him to take off
his mask and when he does,
Jamie sees a tear running down his face.
She even comments on his humanity.
- You're just like me.
- I'm an ***hole just like you.
- Hmm.
- However, Michael's moment
of humanity peeking through
is short lived, when Jamie
tries to wipe away his tears
and the rage takes back over.
She runs downstairs, and when
Michael comes down to find her
he finds Dr. Loomis offering her to him?
This must have been a
surprising turn of events.
It would be like if Susan
just showed up at my door
and handed me the gold creator award.
Of course, it turns out to be a trap,
which if Susan shows up at my door,
I'm definitely gonna assume it's a trap.
- Shut that door.
- [Zac] A large net of heavy
metal chains falls from above,
considerably slowing down his movement
as he loads Michael up
with tranquilizer darts,
then just goes to town with a plank.
- Die! Die! Die! Die! Michael!
Die!
- Yeah.
Michael wakes up in jail,
but this time his stay in
captivity wouldn't last long,
as Dr. Wynn decided to take
matters into his own hands
to make sure his protege
lives up to expectations.
Wynn single-handedly
raids the police station.
He makes quick work of the
seven officers stationed there
and blows the door off of Michael's cell
where the two can make a quick getaway.
Despite being free again, it
would be a number of years
before the planets aligned properly
for Michael to make his next Samhain--
- [Loomis] Sam Hain.
- Sacrifice.
Now if you're riding along with
us on the Halloween Express,
we've just finished Halloween 5
and we're moving on to The
Curse of Michael Myers.
There are two versions of this movie,
the Theatrical Cut and the Producer's Cut,
which was publicly released later.
They're basically the same movie,
the biggest difference is the endings,
which is why you'll ride
all the way into the station
with us no matter which one you choose,
and your decision will only really dictate
which platform you exit to.
The Theatrical Cut is technically canon,
so that's the direction
I'll be heading in,
but if you wanna see me talk
about the Producer's Cut,
check out the Things You Missed episode.
It's been six years since
Michael escaped the jail cell,
leading many to speculate
on if he is dead or alive.
It is October 30th, 1995,
and Jamie Lloyd is pregnant
with her first child.
She's kidnapped by the Cult of Thorn
shortly before the delivery
so that they can pass
the curse onto the baby
or let Michael kill both of them,
but a nice nurse helps her
escape with her first born.
After six years of waiting in the shadows,
Michael is dispatched to stop them.
He pins the helpful nurse up on a wall,
completing his trilogy
of wall-art victims,
and snaps the neck of a random guy
who gets in between him and Jamie,
but she manages to get away in a vehicle.
Michael uses a Smith's
Grove van to hunt her
and runs her off the road
into a pumpkin patch.
She attempts to hide inside
of the adjacent barn,
but having just delivered a baby that day,
there's not much more
energy or fight in her,
and after seven years of waiting,
Michael finally brings
his niece's life to an end
by picking her up and skewering her
on this piece of farming equipment.
It seems like she's already
done for at this point,
but just to make sure,
he proceeds to turn on
said farming equipment.
For the first time in 32 years,
he actually managed to make
some progress on his main goal,
which is sacrificing his family members.
Unfortunately for him,
he cannot be freed from
his curse just yet,
because now he has Jamie's
baby to track down.
- [Loomis] She is the
last of his bloodline.
- [Tommy] No Dr. Loomis.
She's not the last.
- [Zac] The next day is
Halloween, October 31st, 1995.
Just as he always does when
he returns to Haddonfield,
Michael visits his childhood home,
but this time he finds
another family living there.
This is the Strode family,
the relatives of the
couple that adopted Laurie
all those years ago.
Naturally, Michael is not anymore a fan
of someone else living in his old room
than he was 17 years ago,
so he deals with these negative emotions
the same way he deals
with everything in life,
by killing them.
The mother, Debra Strode
gets cut down with an axe,
but Michael, in maybe the nicest thing
he's ever done for anyone,
is courteous enough to
put her stuff in the wash.
It looks like she had spilled
some cherry slurpee on it.
The father, John Strode, is
thrown into a breaker box
and electrocuted.
Like Mikey's car six years
before, he inexplicably explodes?
John and Debra's son Tim
and his girlfriend Beth
are at the live airing
of a Haddonfield Halloween radio special.
Michael goes there and ambushes
the host inside of his van.
The body would later fall out of a tree,
terrifying the spectators.
Later still, he returns
home, where Tim and Beth
are already getting hot and heavy.
Tim jumps in the shower afterwards
and asks Beth to bring him a towel,
but Michael brings one instead.
Tim doesn't notice the thorn
symbol on his wrist though,
so Michael gives him the old
throat slash when he gets out,
then proceeds to stab Beth in the back.
In the theatrical cut, the
edit is very YouTube Poop-ish.
[Ganon] Die!
(ominious music)
That just leaves John and
Debra's daughter, Kara Strode,
and her son Danny as the last
two inhabitants of the house.
Kara manages to hide in a dark corner
and knock Michael down the stairs,
making her the first
one to knock Michael out
with her bare hands.
He comes back and grabs her ankle
as she's trying to get
Danny to safety though,
and she's only able to escape by
whacking him with a fire poker.
He chases them back across the
street to the boarding house,
but Dr. Wynn and the other cult members
are waiting for them there,
so Michael is instructed
to return to his home away from home,
The Smith's Grove Sanitarium.
(upbeat music)
That brings us to the last morning
of the original Halloween
timeline, November 1st, 1995.
November 1st is one of the
worst days of the year as it is,
because it's the furthest
day from Halloween
on the calendar.
I can only imagine that having
an immortal serial killer
after you on that day doesn't
make it any easier to swallow.
Jamie's baby, who's been
named Stephen Strode,
and Kara's son Danny Strode are captured.
We have to do a little bit of guesswork
to figure out what the
cult's overall plan here is,
but I think the plan is to kill the baby,
which would effectively lift
the Curse of Thorn from Michael
and give them the opportunity
to place it on Danny.
That would explain
why he's been hearing
the voices in his head,
just like the six-year old Michael did
the evening before he was
possessed to kill Judith.
Michael's quiet yet destructive demeanor
has surprised many of his
60+ victims over the years,
but what he does next is a
different kind of surprise.
Michael turns against the Cult of Thorn.
(bloodcurdling scream)
- He walks amongst us brother.
He's come back.
And he's very angry.
- [Zac] Tommy and Kara have
one close encounter with him
and then he just walks into the lab
and starts cutting down
doctors, nurses and surgeons
left and right.
If you work in medicine in Haddonfield,
just take the day off
on Halloween, seriously.
We're left yet again
to wonder why Michael's
behaviour changes so suddenly.
I've seen it suggested
that he was just tired
of obeying the cult.
I think that makes no sense,
why would he turn on them
when he was potentially so
close to breaking the curse
after 32 years?
I see it as more of a
caged bear situation.
While Michael is possessed by Thorn,
he's essentially like a wild animal.
Anyone who gets too close
is in danger of being killed
by him, that's just his nature,
what he does.
He doesn't have any real allegiances,
but he does still have the goal
of killing off his next of kin.
I'm not saying that he's
incapable of thinking for himself,
we see him sneak up on people
and make reactionary decisions
throughout the series,
I'm just saying if he
has the chance to kill,
he's probably going to.
During this massacre,
one of the medics escapes
out into the hall,
and that's when he sees
Tommy and Kara trying to flee
with the two young kids.
This is the first time in a while
that Michael is really close
to completing his main task,
that is, wiping out his bloodline,
so we see him actually walking faster
than he's ever walked before.
Tommy closes up this gate
in order to create a barrier
between them and Michael,
which totally screws over
this medic for no reason.
Michael bashes the
guy's face into the bars
and then just knocks down the gate anyway.
Having spent 15 years there,
this is kind of like Michael's home turf,
so he's able to take some kind
of shortcut to cut them off.
They duck into a random lab
filled with human embryos
or babies growing in tanks.
Some think that this means Jamie
was artificially
inseminated to have Stephen,
others believe this was a setup
for a seventh Halloween film
that never happened.
I don't think either of
those makes that much sense
because these embryos are
clearly growing into babies
outside the body, this
isn't a typical IVF lab.
And this lab scene was actually added
for the Theatrical Cut after
the death of Donald Pleasance,
who plays Loomis.
It would have been an
excellent opportunity
to tie up any loose
threads, not cast new ones.
Feel free to share your
own interpretations though.
Michael punches through the
door to get access to the lab,
and Tommy seems to concede to
him and offers up the baby,
but of course it's just an
empty bundle of blankets.
Tommy stabs four syringes into him
and then Kara hits him
with a pipe over and over.
He pins her to a lab table and chokes her,
but lets her go after Danny yells out
and gives away his position.
- [Danny] Leave her alone!
- Michael realizes that Danny has the baby
and attempts to seize him,
but Tommy drugs him one last time,
giving Kara and the kids a
chance to make a run for it.
Then Tommy beats him up with
a pipe Dr. Loomis style.
Yeah, he's a little too
proud of himself there.
And believe it or not,
that is the last we ever see
of the original iteration
of Michael Myers.
The Theatrical Cut ends
with the suggestion
of some kind of confrontation
between Michael and Loomis,
where Loomis managed to get his mask off,
but judging by this sound,
- [Loomis] Aaargh!
- I am led to believe
that Michael ultimately
got the upper hand.
The original continuity
ended with a whimper
in terms of box-office revenue.
Four, five and six
represent three of the four
lowest grossing Halloween movies
as of 2021.
I don't really care about that,
but from a horror perspective,
it makes sense why the series
was falling out of favor.
The Cult of Thorn storyline
gives an explanation to
Michael Myers's creepy
and unpredictable behaviour,
and in a way, that
demystifies the character.
- For years I've been convinced
that there must be some reason.
Some method behind Michael's madness.
- But at the same time, as
we've seen in this video,
there is still a lot to speculate about.
I think back to the
sheer look of confusion
when Laurie removes
Michael's mask in 1978.
Michael operates at his
highest potential when he,
the mysteries of his character,
and his true intentions
are properly masked.
Click that playlist on the
left for my entire catalogue
of Halloween franchise
Horror History episodes.
If you love horror and
all things Halloween,
remember to subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week,
ring the deathbell and
select all notifications
and I will see you in the next one.
Assuming the planets align.
(upbeat music)